centennial hills hospital expanding its  services to its first free standing  emergency department  it's going to be located on decatur and  elkhorn which is in the north part of  town  not too far from the dmv if you're  familiar with it ground broke today  at the er at valley vista it'll be used  as an extension of the hospital's  existing emergency department  the facility will feature medical exam  rooms advanced imaging services and  on-site decontamination rooms as well  we've seen a consistent amount of growth  from the north las vegas perspective in  terms of overall population  and housing growth and so this  development will certainly help  to better support the growing needs of  this community  the e.r expected to open at the end of  this year